most of us are familiar with dogs
oftentimes known as man's best friend
and what's fascinating about them is
that they are one species even though
different types of dogs different breeds
could look very very different and the
fact that they're one specie says that
if you have a male and a female dog any
two that in theory they could reproduce
and produce viable offspring although in
for example the case of this character
in this character the mechanics could
get quite difficult but an interesting
question is is where do dogs come from
and why do we have these seemingly
specialized breeds amongst dogs you
might have things like a Rottweiler
that's better for protection you might
have things like Terriers that would
have been specialized to maybe we go
after rodents you have things like
Border Collies that are good at herding
other types of animals the simple answer
is through artificial selection and
domestication remember in any population
of a species there's variation in that
species and when we talked about natural
selection that's where the environment
might select for certain of those
variants certain of those variants might
make it a little bit easier to survive
or reproduce and then those would
predominate and that's how evolution
happens our official selection and
domestication is where humans take
matters into their own hands and instead
of waiting for nature to do things they
are the selection factor they pick which
of the species get to reproduce and
which ones don't and when you have that
type of artificial selection the change
can happen much much faster breeding is
essentially artificial selection so dogs
like this and all the dogs we know of
had ancestors that look like this that
looked like a wolf that were a wolf and
what we theorize is that the early
stages of some Wolf's eventually
evolving into dogs might have been more
traditional natural selection where tens
of thousands of years ago our
hunter-gatherer ancestors as they hunted
and gathering they might have leftover
food here there and some of the wolves
that just happen to be the variants that
were a little bit more comfortable
getting close to humans might have
benefited from being able to get some of
that leftover food being able to get
some of that
the remains that the human beings left
behind but then over time human beings
probably realize that hey these wolves
are useful to have around maybe they're
they provide some form of protection
maybe over time they started breeding
the wolves so the wolves that were
especially friendly the wolves that were
especially good at a certain task say
protection or going after some type of
an animal or retrieving things they
allow those to reproduce together and
over time over tens of thousands of
years we went from wolves to dogs and
even once we had dogs the breeding got
even more specialized as I mentioned
things like Border Collies this was many
years many generations of breeding where
sheep herders might have selected dogs
that were good at herding sheep that
Terriers came from dogs that were good
at going after rodents things like
Rottweilers or dog's breeding the dogs
that were especially good at providing
protection or defense and it isn't just
dogs that are products of artificial
selection and domestication pretty much
any animal that you might see on say a
farm would be the product of artificial
selection and domestication a wild pig
looks like this while the ones that you
would see on a farm looked like that and
once again they would have selected for
things like facility things where
they're less aggressive and they're
easier to take care of and artificial
selection and domestication does not
apply just to animals pretty much
anything you might see in the produce
section of your supermarket is the
product of artificial selection and
domestication there might be wild
variants of these different vegetables
or these different fruits over roughly
ten or fifteen thousand years of human
agriculture every generation of crop
they would have selected for the crops
that are more robust that tasted better
that were able to grow in different
climates and by allowing those variants
to reproduce we eventually ended up with
the domesticated crops we see today